foreign
let's go to Sarah in Philadelphia what's
up Sarah how we doing
uh
how are you I am trying my best to not
get my show canceled but Kelly's intent
on us not having a show anymore so
what's up
15 year old son has expressed an
interest in um and a desire to possibly
move in with his father and I don't
think it's a good idea and of course I
don't want him to go
um but I don't know what to do like is
this something he has to do is this
something I can stop because I don't
think it's what's best for him I don't
know where to go
um tell number one I hate that I'm sorry
for all of you good grief what a mess
it's been a mess for a long time
she doesn't accurately remember what it
was like when his father and I were
together he thinks it was this beautiful
fantasy land where everything was
perfect and his dad was always there and
always taking care of him and I think he
just wants that because that was never
true yeah of course and he's filled in
the gaps with movies and TV shows and
conversations with his buddies and he
has created a caricature of the man who
was in his life before
his mom screwed everything up and left
and here we are right exactly
um
tell me about Dad
so I'm going to tell you that he's not a
bad dad but he's also not a good dad
he's like in the middle somewhere
um that's hard for me to imagine so give
me some context okay so like
when they go to his house he lives two
hours away so he's not in town so when
they go to his house um every other
weekend so it's 26 weekends a year when
they go to his house
they sometimes go on hikes
um they play a lot of video games they
kind of sit around a lot and play video
games but he does take them for a bike
ride or for a hike normally once during
the weekend
um
and he does reschedule at least five or
six of those weekends a year so it's
kind of like you know I don't have HD
concerns for them when they're at their
dad's house I mean when they were
younger I did but now that they're all
older I don't
um but
but you know the difference you know the
reality there he would move into
yeah and like we're you know I I'm
remarried I have a husband who I adore
and my husband's been in my kids lives
for
um I mean we've been married now for
seven years so
um
like we show up we coach we're on the
sidelines we're cheering for them you
know we're always like I go to all the
school meetings I volunteer I you know I
do all these things to be part of their
lives and to try and make sure that you
know they have the sports they want to
play and stuff like that and like he
does not do that he has never done that
and hold on hold on there's some more to
it than that you have to understand this
is not a son making a statement about
his mom
yeah this is not a son making a
statement about his stepdad
this is a son wondering what the hell
was so wrong with me that my dad left
and he will spend the rest of his life
trying to solve that problem
even if it means going from stability
and love and connectivity to chaos
yeah he has to
figure out what he did wrong
and it's a hard this is one of those
back end things why divorce is so tough
even when it's a hundred percent
necessary
is these little ones in the middle are
left wondering what they did to
contribute
and there's no amount of telling them
nothing nothing nothing
especially when the something
is a larger than life figure
23 or 22 times a year
yeah and does all the cool things that
mom doesn't let us do
well and when he comes to his currently
when my oldest son goes here we go and
we do like
my other two sons with my ex-husband
they don't seem to have I mean they're
not as favored as my oldest son by my
ex-husband like my ex-husband just my
oldest son on vacation last year and did
not take the other two
um
so it's very clear that they're not as
favored as he is
um but when he comes home
from his dad's from the weekend it's
like three days of him hating me of
course the re-entry is it's it's yes
absolutely
and he says stuff like
now I'm always someone like I
I never bad boss my ex I think to the
point where like not that I should ever
badmouth him in front of the kids but to
the point where I think I've kind of
glossed over things that really weren't
okay like
maybe even made the kids feel like you
know if I'm upset I shouldn't be upset
because mom says that Dad loves me and
stuff like that sure
um
but apparently I just found out recently
he's been bad-mouthing me quite a bit
sure and telling the kids that like I
took them away from him and
all this kind of stuff and I was having
a conversation with him with an earshot
of my kids
and he started accusing me of cheating
on him which wasn't true
um and all these other things and I'm
like I'm not going to speak to you about
this right now and he was at my house
and I was like you need to leave my
house right now
um
but it's just like I don't know what to
do because I feel like if he
he moves down there is he just gonna
hate me like he's gonna believe all
these things because I you know never
really discussed this stuff with him so
he doesn't know any other side of the
story right
here's what I I'm just I'm fast
forwarding because this is a complex
issue and it's not one that I can just
say yeah you need to do this or do this
um my gut tells me he needs to stay with
you guys
and my gut tells me that that's going to
come at an extreme relational cost
or to put it more directly there's no
way to win here
and so we're going to do the right thing
even when it's hard
like you see what I'm saying so
um
if I were you
I would tell him I'm willing to consider
this
but we are going to go you and him are
gonna go see a counselor together for a
minimum of two months three months
whatever
and in this conversation the counselor
can help guide the conversation about
living arrangements why he wants to move
maybe then slowly and gently and
appropriately introduce here's the
reality of Dad
sometimes the counselor can ask
questions that
appear to put you on the spot that you
have to answer
um but that
makes the counselor the to to the bad
guy if you will and not Mom not Mom just
sitting down at breakfast live in
grenades about Dad but Mom asking
truthful questions about like yeah dad
was abusive
um I had to leave for my own safety or I
had I was trying to keep you guys safe
and all of those are going to be
damaging to him because and you probably
heard me say this he knows innately half
of him is that guy and half of him is
you and he has to make that other half
right even if that means glossing over
glaring issues like abuse not showing up
rescheduling forgetting
all those you just play video games
while I'm doing some stuff outside like
he's gonna gloss over all of it because
he has to make it right because that's
part of him and if he's not good then
I'm not good
okay and it's so messy so messy
that's why I it makes me so sick that he
would talk bad about you
well and that's I have divorced parents
so when I had like when I split up for
my ex-husband one of the things we
talked about was I was like we can never
bad mouth each other because you have to
remember that half of our kids are each
other
and it makes them feel like that half of
themselves is wrong or bad or horrible
exactly and like that's a horrible
horrible feeling to cross like that I
was like I don't like they can't have
that and now like and I don't think he's
just my son down and says like here's a
laundry list of things that are horrible
about your mother he just makes like
little comments and he makes
significantly more money than I do and
his household makes like probably three
times as much so when they go down there
it's like we can go out to dinner and we
can and it just all adds up into this
this perfect storm of like
my oldest son just eating
our house and being here yeah and he's
just and it's chaotic too there's five
kids two of which are you know someone
else's day like the whole thing and then
yeah you dangle this
um Daddy Warbucks situation in front of
him the whole thing's just a mess and on
top of it I actually think if he sat
your son down and was like your mom's
the worst your son would have some
defense mechanisms
like well hey that's partly me too and
he would think through it and be like
well mom hugs me that's I mean 14 year
olds are pretty Sharp
I think the more Insidious ones are
they're driving and he just puts his
hand on your son's head and tussles his
hair and says wouldn't it be awesome if
we could do this all the time
wouldn't it be cool if your mom would
like let us do this all the time but she
like I mean she went to court and said I
can never see you and that's why we
can't do this all the time
that is the stuff that is Insidious
because there's no comeback for that
yeah
and I hate that that's happening to you
I'm sorry the hardest part for you is
going to be not taking this personal
it's a four a 14 year old trying to find
out what he did that was so bad and
trying to figure out why half of him is
so chose to leave
yeah and I'm trying to like not take it
oh I know dude I'm asking you like if
it's me man I would be taking all this
personally and you hear me say all the
time like your kids can't make you feel
anything no I'd feel terrible I would
choose to feel terrible right it's the
worst it's the worst I'm asking you do
the impossible I know
but that's that's where I think bringing
the counselor in and be prepared the
counselor may say I think the best thing
is to spend a year there
yeah and y'all you and your new husband
you'll have that conversation would we
allow this what would it look like what
are the rules what are the guidelines
what does the court say about it um you
may get there and I don't know enough
about your son I don't know enough about
your divorce decree and I don't know
enough about
[Music]
um
what the long-term ramifications would
that would be for him individually and
your family unit
um for him to go away for a year and try
it out
um I've heard of it happening and it's
I've never heard of it going well
like dad's True Colors show themselves
eventually
yeah and he originally my son was
talking about trying it out over the
summer for like
the thing I've actually offered
to my ex-husband like
you know would you like to have the kids
for like a month during the summer solid
months or like you know six weeks or
something like that so that you can like
really spend time with them and I always
try and give him extra time whenever
there is you know time because I know
that the kids like being down there
um you know we have behavior problems
with my younger son with him because
when he comes back he's played video
games the whole weekend and he can't
control himself at school of course but
um he's never been interested in taking
me up on this and all of a sudden he's
interested and I think it's because just
recently he changed our support
agreement and he no longer is able to
claim my oldest son on his taxes and it
just cost him like four thousand dollars
on his taxes
um yeah he would if he's doing if he's
doing well financially he wouldn't do
something this dramatic for four
thousand dollars
well
I mean you'd have to be really bad with
mathematics to think a four thousand
dollar tax write-off versus living every
day with a 15 year old is gonna save you
money
I agree I know how expensive my kids are
it's ridiculous yes and he's just now
getting into driver's education and
driving and dating and like he's about
things about to get real expensive
if you think he also likes to tell me
all the time that the kids shouldn't do
their extracurricular activity like
they're too expensive you need to stop
letting them do that and you need to
stop spending on that and that and I'm
always like of course no and that's why
I say maybe with the support of a
therapist some of those conversations
are going to come out
and maybe maybe you nailed it maybe just
trying in the month of July to see what
it's like
because here's what I'm thinking off top
of my head a lot of the data suggests
that when
um a husband and a wife split up and she
takes the kids
her income her net worth goes down his
accelerates exponentially
and generally it's because he can take
as many shifts as he want he can work
overtime he can go get another degree if
he wants he's not trying to tread water
and so it's not uncommon for there to be
a ton of money that just ends up in this
trajectory because he's got no Anchor
Point right he can do what he wants and
then once a week and he's I mean once a
month he gets a free-for-all and then
you go ride go-karts and play video
games and eat Lucky Charms for every
every meal and then he can just return
back to his real life when you and your
family unit have to absorb the The
Fallout from all that all that to say
um
I think it would be best to sit down
with somebody a professional and say and
tell your son I'm willing to have the
conversation
but there's a lot of the story that you
don't know
and I believe with all of my heart that
the respectful kind thing to do is to
always talk good about your dad and so
I've done that and we're gonna have to
if you wanna if you want me to entertain
this then you're gonna have to go with
me for a period of time with a counselor
and we're gonna have some direct open
conversations and about you about your
thoughts about your ideas about safety
about my concerns
um and then we'll go from there off the
top of my head I don't like it it feels
like a 15 year old's gonna get dropped
off in Neverland and who knows what
happens next
but I'm not an expert here and so I I
want to concede this one to somebody
who's going to have a real good inside
of you and your family
at the end of the day
I promise you he'll come back
I promise you you're playing a long game
with him
and so six months a year two years he's
gonna come back and he's gonna one day
see
man that woman never gave up on me
and she loved me and loved me and tried
and tried and kept showing up and kept
showing up and kept showing up
hang in there Sarah he's lucky to have
you